i'm making a hard left because i
realized i had a tab here open i'm very
comfortable in the hard left you know
that awesome uh yeah i i realized we
actually recorded last time before
uh the game awards and i didn't actually
ask you if you ended up watching them
like i assumed the next day or if you i
i saw i saw some of the trailers but i
didn't watch the awards
well there aren't to be fair there
really aren't any awards it's uh always
if not do they not do the whole it's not
like the oscars i'm being
snarky it's just like the ratio of
trailers to awards is
is uh
highly one-sided um
and this
brings out some ire in certain people
myself included ir maybe is too strong a
word i i i you'd like like a 10-minute
speech for every single category and
like
i mean
i find myself really of a lot of
different minds i i spoke with i i spoke
with uh troy a bit at length it looks
like he's not gonna be able to make it
he had the start time wrong and and
uh
anyway
um so he so
he
i hope he doesn't mind my saying he
tends to be a bit of a of a defender of
it and a real believer in it and and
recognizing that like
the goal of having a massive event that
really does get seen by tens of millions
as a way to kind of
you know do what the oscars
theoretically
um
you know
yeah and that there are certain things
trade-offs
that are implicit in that and that the
trailers and sponsorships and those
kinds of things
just go with the territory to make it
financially viable and
in that sense i fully agree i i think as
an entrepreneur
keeley clearly
has uh you know found a winning formula
given the size of the audience like i'm
i'm i you know if the people keep
showing up and each year there's more
people showing up to watch it and
they're actually excited um and then
obviously you've got also
the the circular aspect of companies
increasingly willing to pay you know
what i assume are hefty sums to have a
prominent trailer placement in the show
knowing it's going to get seen by a lot
of people and and to that end you know a
handful of people in their speeches said
something like
you know our game had its premier
trailer four years ago on this stage
nobody knew who we were and now here we
are winning you know whatever best
online game or however and like this
event is probably why we're even in a
position to have an audience that size
and so like
i'm not inclined to dismiss any of that
i think that that's pretty amazing
um i realized
i was like but why does it still bother
me uh why does the event still feel like
it's so because there's two things
the idea that the awards are so
secondary compared to all the reveals
make it feel like all you developers who
are you know this is supposed to be like
your night your first and maybe only
time to live in the limelight and know i
did something that made a difference and
i'm being acknowledged by you know my
peers in the industry or whatever and
like i get because
not only are the you know the the awards
that are on stage few and far between by
and large but further um
two-thirds or half the categories they
just run through really quick they go
okay and uh best um like music the best
music the winner was this okay and best
uh persistent online games oh you don't
have the thing where the composer goes
up on stage thanks oh okay only on
certain categories uh only
that's a time thing right like they're
going we wanna we have to do this many
trailers we're only on for two i'm not
saying this is correct by the way but
that's the logic right i do believe that
three that's like yeah i think that's
the thinking and again as an
entrepreneur i can't fault him but as
somebody who says you know
some people
it's the first and only time they'll
ever be nominated for anything in their
whole life and to just be
um a passing ref like best vr title was
one and some friends of mine were
nominated in that category and they lost
so they they
they worked for four years on a game
half of which was in a pandemic it
nearly you know crushed their whole
company but they managed to see it
through and ship a game that they're
really proud of and their sort of one
moment is to be on a list of here are
the nominees and the winner is resident
evil congrats and like he was like you
know he tweeted something like you know
hey still worth it to make the game but
you know
like
that
doesn't they don't feel
terribly respected but i did have an
epiphany because i buy into all that and
i go yeah it doesn't feel like it's
really about celebrating the art
it's it's it's about selling
what's next and that's fundamentally
different from what i think an award
show is about which made me realize
maybe i'm just so shallow and
simple-minded that i wouldn't feel any
of these ways if they just changed the
name of it to
like the game
show like the the games show or
something like that instead of it was if
the awards were
defined as tertiary by the name
is it the fact that it's being called
the game awards that that kind of ins
invites the criticism you're saying
right yeah because i realized i the more
the more i dug into it and again credit
to troy for really kind of forcing me to
examine where my um
attitudes were coming from because i
realized i didn't have good arguments
until i realized oh it's really just
about the framing of calling it an award
show
and then
um
and then making the awards seem so
unimportant which to me i just end up
feeling bad for all these people
being nominated and winning especially
in the less sexy categories of game of
the year and that sort of thing i will
say though it was a bit of a highlight
that game of the year went to it takes
two
with this you know joseph ferris uh sort
of and he's a he's a mainstay isn't he
of that show well he he kind of
and he his whole crazy like [ __ ] the
oscars thing that went on and he like
lost his mind on stage a few years ago
and it made him a little bit of a
he made him a little bit of like the
unfolte of the game awards to then win
in earnest
um
uh was actually a pretty cool way to end
the night i thought um and it's always
nice when a game that's sort of
very unexpected takes the the game of
the year there's something like i'll
never forget
when um
at the baftas in 2013 when journey was
like nominated in a million categories
and it won all of them except game of
the year which went to dishonored
you wanted a couple that we were up for
if i recall
really was it thomas was alone i think i
think thomas was uh i thought that was
the year after the league
no it was 20 no that no was
so that would have been yeah so it was
it would no was i remember i think i
think i'm right i think you be thomas
was alone on the music i think you and
dave are up against each other
well son of a [ __ ]
yeah
i thought i swore that you guys that
that game came out i feel like we've
even talked about this here forgive me
thomas was alone people think came out
later than it was that it did because it
it bombed at launch so it was one there
was definitely a slow burn in terms of
the audience but yeah i was going to
bring up the baftas because i do like i
mean
i did
i did beat mr houston well that's why i
throw darts at a journey box in the
corner while i'm working that's so i i i
um
yeah the baftas is obviously gets that
balance completely in the direction of
the awards but i imagine probably less
people watch them afterwards right
by someone so exactly that's why the the
um that's why the entrepreneur in me
says i can't deny that he has made a
thing that far more people care about
than than like the baftas the dice
awards you know these are all uh things
like that
you know like our colleagues people if
you win a dice award or a bafta
internally to the industry i think
there's a fair bit of respect associated
with that's respected um but the general
public of people actually buying the
games don't even know or care i think
and that's where i'm like you know i
gotta i gotta give him credit
um
for
[Music]
uh
for creating a thing that the general
public does seem to care about and you
know and similarly the oscars have been
in just a continuous ratings decline
and it makes me wonder maybe it's
because
at the end of the day especially now
with social media access a glimpse of
celebrity which is what one of the main
things the oscars promised yeah it's far
less novel than it was in years past and
also
we're just less likely to listen to
authority aren't we i think in terms of
specifically in terms of taste in terms
of like what's popular i think people
look at something like squid game i
think i don't think people waiting for
some critic or award ceremony to say
that squid game was good they heard from
two mates it was good so they tried and
they liked it and et cetera et cetera
right that's like i don't wonder if
people don't care and as well because
everyone's in their niche that like if
you if you think the best film that came
out last year was such and such you can
find a community who agrees with you and
you can get content talking about how
right you are like you necessarily look
to that authoritative kind of oh well
the academy thinks this like i don't
know i don't know if i i know our
generation probably still does because
we're we're from a different generation
but i bet i can't imagine the average 15
20 year old nowadays gives a [ __ ]
about any of that yeah you know i i
think that that's interesting and it
makes me wonder kind of related to that
you know we've talked here like when
solitaire came out you were talking
about the you know the
important multiple awards soul attack
conspiracy multiple you were you were
talking about the uh the metacritic um
um importance of that but it makes me
wonder is it would that not also be
symptomatic of the same thing like
should theoretically that also kind of
fall by the wayside as something that we
care about because i don't know that
critic is falling by the wayside in
terms of sorry not the website sorry i'm
just blurry i'm just going to fix that
i don't think it's i think i think the
audience the younger audience care less
about it it's a it's a there's a like
just from like in terms of i don't see
necessarily a correlation between our
metacritic scores and how well a
specific game is done like it's it's
kind of it's it seems to be what
connects is different
but also um the joke that's hilarious is
like among indie devs like often the
games that are doing really well in the
indie space are games that the
mainstream game press just have never
covered i i remember um callum post uh
uh among us among us didn't had i don't
think among us qualified for a
metacritic score until like a year a
month ago
like it's like
like
there's an audience that aren't looking
again like they're looking to it matters
what your friends are into what your
community's into what you know your
peers or influencers they're into maybe
but like you don't necessarily look to
that stuff anymore so i still like you
know i've been i've been the guy who's
super into critics on this show many
times like i still massively respect a
good game critic is is fascinating read
and very useful and it's part of when
i'm appraising whether i want to play a
game i definitely look to the review
scores but again i think maybe that's a
generational thing and i think
but i don't think i've ever
pulled the trigger to buy a game or
or
not
i think i've been like mid-purchase and
then been curious you know okay and then
been like oh definitely
like metacritic on like a console game
say like i will absolutely take a look
at metric for a console game when it
comes out and then on steam games
there's many steam games i've bought
just based on going to the page and
going oh wow 98 positive i guess this is
cool like in terms of the user reviews
but again that's user reviews right
which is different again so it's i don't
know i think it's transitioning and i
think
yeah the user reviews on steam that
feels infinitely more valuable i would
think to assessing yeah a game uh you
know like people
willing to even right
very interestingly steam reviews can
wait very very drastically in a way
that's interesting if you if you have
any kind of controversy say about your
game
um
of course you know if the bad people on
the internet say you're an sjw or
something like your score can go very
bad
if you but also conversely like if
you're saying that's worthy but like
you know it's whatever it can go very
high with which maybe doesn't reflect
what the game's called here so it's it's
more malleable in that sense just
because it's not professionalized the
people giving reviews are not being paid
by someone to do it so therefore it's uh
it's a bit more of a free-for-all that
said i love my steam reviews please keep
giving me positive steam reviews
y'all talking about steam reviews right
now
we've gone we're yeah we're via via
criticism and awards we've basically
done like a plot i feel like we've done
a potted history of the first year of
the podcast
[Laughter]
last 25 minutes no we've been chatting
about uh game awards a little bit
yeah just in time to be absolutely
irrelevant to the same placement that
you'd get for the thumbnail it's all
right it seemed like related to the
party
it seemed like alana took one look at us
and then was like i'm out she's signing
up
no cameras today guys i accidentally had
i try to just keep my little work corner
that i have outside of um
oh view ada's
i mean
technically
there we go
there's a lot kratos behind you i think
there's a whole lot of greatest behind
me it's true
it's it's he looks so mad okay
that's exactly how i've always pictured
your workspace it's just boxes large
boxes
and uh in a boulder yeah on a low key
there is a loki in there also yes yes
actually inside those is literally like
the the actual person
yeah there's no halls he's dead for sure
yeah yeah that's my one has two ps6 dev
kits in it
and she can't show to the camera
um i feel like i didn't see
a ton of criticism uh regarding it takes
to winning
um
it was just like like we had spoken
about a really strange year in terms of
like not knowing who was gonna win game
of the year but i i'm so stoked for his
light like
even though it would not have been my
pick that game is so creative it i'm so
happy for them just like it's it's just
nothing like anything else that's ever
won before
austin was saying like how nice it is
when something comes along and surprises
the audience yeah
especially in his case where you know
he's kind of like he's no one who would
even know who he was i think if it
weren't for his little rant on stage a
few years ago
and like in terms of the general public
at least uh and so there's something
gratifying
uh because he didn't
it's easy for someone to have a moment
like that to then become this cartoon
character in our minds collectively
where every time they're on stage we
expect them to be like oh what's it
gonna do this time and he came across
very genuine i felt uh he did still say
the f word
i mean it's the game industry is that a
shock
i know it's true but he's the only one
to swear so it is it is notable and i
was excited for him do it it's like he's
good is he gonna say a sweat such a
rebel he did it
that's funny well that may be the one
loophole in what i'm talking about but
he came across to me as you know
a genuine uh
a genuine dude who you know has evolved
and also you know like
he came across
the word the least charitable take on
him when he was up there saying we're
going to make the best game ever
everyone's going to see and he was
promoting that prison escape
game um and
you know it there's a certain
um
like hustler quality some people can
have when they're they're just selling
you so hard you know he's like you'll
see you'll see this is gonna be the best
thing aren't you in that situation you
are you are shilling your products yeah
it's like a certain former u.s president
who just always felt like there's
there's an angle everything is about the
sales pitch it's never really about the
quality
which
famously a terrible human being as well
um well fair yeah true um
um
but uh
but yeah i i think that um
that the fact that he had he didn't
appear to be a con artist because you
know he ended up shipping a game that
that like that's i think the third game
of that because because they did one
other in between it takes to end the
prison game um
if i'm remembering correctly um
i thought there was one before prison
game or maybe that's what it is brothers
first though yeah brothers yeah oh right
well what's the prison one called go way
out
yeah
all of which are good um and i don't i
get what you're saying about sales pitch
thing but my thing with him is that he
uh
believes everything he's saying i
genuinely believe that he thinks what
he's saying is true he's not trying to
con you
yeah no i that's why i said it's sort of
an uncharitable take on him to say he's
hustling you
because he comes across similarly to
people that that don't believe what they
say at least in that one [ __ ] the oscars
moment
but in america does the word hustle mean
like does it have a connotation of being
dishonest
it's funny
it wouldn't in my opinion yeah i i i
would say not because i would assume i
think it's possible to be honest and
hustling simultaneously i for sure agree
that's maybe actually i think i
associate the word hustle with honesty i
think that hustling means you're working
very hard very genuinely but you're
right though because like hustle said in
britain there was a tv show but you can
see
i think this might we might be in a
literally literally position here the
chain the word might have flipped to
mean the opposite no because you can say
you've been hustled and that would
usually mean something negative well in
the old days a hustler was someone who
would like con you a a pool table right
like i i i a friend of mine raised this
whole thing because he's we had this
conversation literally earlier this year
um oh dude literally or do you have it
literally it was it was literally
earlier this year i suppose possible
this might have been might have been
last year because of so it was literally
like this figuratively earlier this year
yeah okay so he um
because he was saying like he's an agent
so he associates hustling with people
who are scrappy and you know and that's
the modern usage and yeah like i
remember i remember when i was in uh
college at nyu and living in manhattan
and i one day i'm walking down the
street
and i just randomly on the streets of
manhattan at like midnight run into a
guy i'd gone to high school with who i
had not seen since high school who was
trying to
uh he had those little flyers and he was
handing them out to passers-by of him
doing stand-up and he was like
and it's like that's hustling and it's
like and i always admired like the
people that are willing to just you know
pound the pavement you know they do what
it takes you know it's it's like when
you walk down hollywood boulevard in
prior years and the guys would hand you
their hip-hop demos um every few seconds
like i got tricked by one guy with that
[ __ ]
the first the first time it happens to
you as a tourist is just like oh i
watched that happen to somebody in la
the other day and he chased them was
like you have to pay for this and they
assume that he's joking and i was like
you do give it back to him
it's terrible um i feel like i did the
digital version of hustling to get my
career started i i
with zero shame emailed every website i
could find with samples and was like
please let me write for free i would
have
to hundreds uh i was i was continuously
writing news even on a blog when i
started to try to get hired and then
submitting it to anybody who would read
it and i feel like that's still hustling
and that i didn't have a lot of shame in
being like i need [ __ ] help please
help me do this um and submitting it to
as many people as i could think of
i think it's evolved i think that's one
of those words that's just shifted a
little bit which is interesting
no i i totally agree i think that it's i
think that it's not um
i think that it's there is no shame in
uh in hustling in that sense and and
that way i kind of retract my usage of
it or i or i acknowledge an antiquated
use of it earlier with talking about
joseph ferris as a side note your
tourist thing reminded me and how do you
feel about andrew jackson
hustler
sort of a
pretzel a frontier a frontier war
hustler
it's just misunderstood if anything
i have a distinct moment of losing my
bright-eyed midwest innocence uh to that
point about the the buying the the
hip-hop cd i remember the first week i
moved to la
i mean to new york i was 18. i'd never
been to a city of that size before um
and
and uh you know i wasn't totally
clueless you know streetwise why why
streetwise wise but um
i um uh i was definitely you know the 18
year old from the suburbs of denver now
living in in manhattan with no guard
rails and and i'll never forget this guy
comes up to me
and he was dressed same exact as me like
t-shirt jeans
you know
completely normal looking dude
and
he says hey man i have a huge favor to
ask do you have like five bucks for the
train into into jersey he goes someone
took my wallet i have literally nothing
i lost my i don't like my i like lost my
wallet in my cell phone or whatever i
just need like five bucks to get home
and then i can sort it out and and i
feel like such an ass even asking but i
don't i literally don't know what else
to do and i'm like oh my god that sounds
terrible like here please and then
[ __ ] six weeks later i'm walking down
the street same guy stops me same word
for word appeared we're in like a
different part of the city and somehow
we found each other again and i was like
it's beautiful you son of a [ __ ] i was
so i felt so violated i was like i
trusted you i was the little i i i came
to the city sure that you needed help
and there's no train to new jersey maybe
it would be hilarious because he's like
i can't believe this happened twice and
he's like legitimately this just the
most is the the home alone two kind of
situations yeah
yeah i feel like at a certain point
giving that speech every time
sounds lengthy is that even that
effective
oh
if he's only getting five dollars every
time how many people like so i don't
carry cash so no matter what i'd be like
oh my god i'm so sorry i don't have any
cash i can't help you that's got to be
25 people don't carry cash maybe
well but still like
it's it's a numbers game isn't it i i
some people would give you more than
five dollars where i genuinely did once
lose my wallet and no one believed me
i mean you notoriously look homeless
yeah that's true the floral shirts
really uh were they were like no one
would buy that that's clearly from like
the salvation army
um
that's so wait what'd you do i don't
know that i've heard this story i oh no
i just i just got caught out i walked
over i was fine but but i was trying to
get a bus
so i literally so i was going off people
going i know i know i know but
seriously
and i was i was asking so i asked
someone for the time and they like uh
you know shuffled away from me in the
street she shouldn't have been
brandishing a knife dude that that'll do
it that will that'll be yeah yeah
but it was definitely like a lesson in
empathy like just to have a moment of
being kind of treated that way like i'm
actively aware people hate hearing this
but i will say if that ever happened to
me i would never ask anyone for help
being a young woman if i was alone and i
lost a wallet i would never ask someone
painter
just
no unless i mean as yeah as a six foot
four
bloke obviously a different context i
get that unless there was a group of of
women maybe i would ask
ah fair enough yeah
yeah no fair play i it is definitely
yeah it's definitely something i can
understand thankfully it's never
happened the one time that i did lose my
wallet um i called my mom so
please help i don't know what to do
maybe 16. it was terrible she had to
drive two hours to help me
that whole idea of it being a lesson in
empathy though um
for sure it reminds me of a few years
ago when joshua bell who's one of the
most famous violinists alive and plays
like this multi-million dollar
stradivarius violin
went he made a bet with i think it was
leonard slatkin one of the famous
conductors where he said
people
don't know
they can't really the average person
doesn't really know what a great
violinist and a great violin are
relative to an average violin and
violinist
and and also
it was this whole thing of you know how
much attention do we pay to buskers you
know street musicians so joshua bell
went into
um the the
um union station like 42nd street in
manhattan
opened up his violin case and started to
play the tchaikovsky violin concerto
which is famously one of the most
daunting pieces for solo violin in the
whole history of classical music and
very few people can do it on his like
multi-million dollar stradivarius and
he's already one of the most famous
theoretically recognizable on the street
if ever a violinist was
um
and he made like in like four hours or
something it was like i think under 200
dollars in tips and maybe even
considerably maybe like 75's i can't
remember now the number but what was
interesting to me was that consistently
it was kids pulling their parents over
to
to
check him out uh because most people now
admittedly he's also
picking up he's planting his flag in one
of the busiest
like commuter train stations very few
people have time to loiter as they pass
through there because they're catching
trains so people rush don't they yeah in
new york they do in general and but also
they that that station is like it's a
big it's a big hub so invariably you're
trying to make sure you don't miss the
next train before so you don't get
screwed for the next you know the next
20 minutes and especially if you have to
catch like a succession of trains in a
row to be able to get home that's a lot
of people and you know people come
commute in from long island and that
sort of thing so there's millions of
people passing through there probably
per day i don't know the actual stats
but it wouldn't surprise me if it's
millions per day you commute in and out
of work they don't just go chill the
only people that ever probably just
chill there are like tourists taking
photos because it's sort of a landmark
building
so it's like a you know he would it
would be more interesting to see if he
went down to like the
you know the statue of liberty or
something where people are
probably more loitery um but still it
was a powerful thing to think this is
literally one of the best on the planet
normally it would cost you hundreds of
dollars to see him like at carnegie hall
and he's just doing this for free and
and people are right
so what you're saying austin is scarcity
adds value to music
it's a flashback i i had i i i saw these
yesterday everything
it's true fair enough speaking of the
speaking of like of the hustle of
buskers i saw the work the basket made
the worst decision ever the other day
and i'm saying pancras there was a there
was a
uh guy i can't remember what instrument
was playing but busking at the at the
train station in full squid game costume
the guard costume from a squid game i'm
like oh you know whatever there was an
aesthetic that i was gonna rush past you
yeah
where the
yeah where the weather the the green
track suit yeah but um let me give you
the actual that's not a good look and he
had like a mate with him so it was two
of them which was very intimidating you
know what i mean it's like i get i get
the logic i get the thought process here
of like being the meme and getting
attention but at the same time like
you're dressed you're covered from head
to toe completely disguised it's kind of
creepy it's it's weird yeah the uh the
final stats were
uh
he a thousand ninety seven people passed
by him i don't know how they measure
that uh or i don't remember how long 27
gave money seven stopped and listened um
and
he made 52 dollars and 17 cents of which
20 came from one person who recognized
him
wow
um i i think like just the to the lesson
in empathy the way that we treat the
homeless is like
terrible whenever you actually stop to
think about it the truth is we never
stop to think about it it's like we just
completely treat them like they don't
exist and imagine being homeless is
number one
um i often think about the inability to
shower if i have to go two days without
a shower i feel awful about myself you
have to do that for six months
uh not to mention not being able to get
food but then also having everybody in
society even if they looked at you and
spoke to you treat you like you don't
exist uh i can't willfully pretend you
don't right literally act like you're a
ghost i can't even imagine what all of
that does to somebody and the truth is
we largely don't find out because
they're homeless they also don't get any
professional um like mental health
support and i think i i hate that i
don't know the name of it um but i
played a game on on dreams
which i love and try to revisit often
because it's so freaking creative oh
where's
yeah somebody tried to emulate the the
homeless experience um it was like maybe
five minutes but it was just that
everything that you would do people
would basically not ever look at you and
would completely like magnetize away
from you and it was like it was like
[ __ ] god we suck and i don't know
what the solution is and there's this
huge thing in la recently did you see
all the stuff with echo park austin
what's that um
kicking them out of the tents and that
yeah so the park um in echo park which
is a really lovely park it's like a
little lake in it
um
had a lot of homeless people living in
it during the pandemic because
naturally homelessness rates increased
and instead of
helping them
uh the council kicked them out and now
the park is permanently gated so it's
like the solution to this problem is to
gate off the park you can enter it
through like two separate entryways i
believe i haven't actually been um but
instead of being like oh well we have
homeless people we have this big
beautiful park it was literally shut the
whole [ __ ] park down nobody goes it's
such a cold we see that time again with
dark patterns don't we dark pattern
design is like as is a field that has
emerged almost entirely because of this
have you heard of dark patterns like i'm
assuming you're referring to like
concrete spikes that stop you from
sleeping
basically design that's designed to
actively harm you as a user making the
button you want to click on the web form
not green making the one that makes the
company that's considered a dark pattern
it's a design that works against your
interest works towards the interest of
whoever set up the button there's a name
for that in design and there's a lot but
yes you're absolutely right from from an
urban planning point of view it's it's
the bench that's intentionally got a
little bump i was just going to bring
that example up i always assumed that's
what that was the the like the like hand
rail in the middle that makes it
impossible to lay down
it's it's it's it's it's a it's it needs
to be acknowledged the key thing with
that is that it's intentional this isn't
accidentally happening it's someone's
for sure
being intentionally uh obstructive
but yeah it's it's that's honestly
that's with homeless folks like
even if you don't have any money in your
pocket just acknowledge them as a human
being just think of them as like you
know in the same ways you give you'd nod
politely to a shopkeeper just
acknowledge the humanity like the number
of times where i've like said hello to
someone on the street and they genuinely
looked like no one said hello to them in
like 24 hours and it's it's horrible but
even that's complicated because you can
argue that you're running a risk which
is also a terrible thing to think about
that's why but if i acknowledge that
privilege raises its ugly head together
am i going to get chased or something
but even that sucks to like look at a
human that way i don't know like i don't
know what the solution is i don't i
don't fault i don't fault anybody for
risk assessment when especially a lot of
the homelessness at least the what i see
here
they can be very aggressive it is very
yeah it is it is a severe mental health
problem where i have i have empathy for
the fact that these are people who are
are victims of circumstance but it does
not feel safe to be around a lot of
a lot of these folks now that said
you know you can't make monolithic
statements obviously i have a friend i
of a composer friend who was homeless
for like three years
and he got involved in this organization
called the street symphony where um la
film musicians
do performances at like skid row
homeless shelters and things like that
um
and um it's an amazing group i i
probably the most impactful experience
i've ever had with music in my life was
when
uh the the founder vijay gupta invited
me to a performance in a prison um that
he was doing with a with a quartet it
was it was five it was quartet plus an
additional cello joshua roman playing
for about 200 women inmates in a prison
downtown la
and um i had to go through this whole
vetting process to go and attend and and
you know have like my background checked
and all this [ __ ] to get inside the
building and then and then and then in
there just sitting in i had no formal i
know involvement i just was a fly on the
wall
and
it was astonishing i've never seen
people more grateful to be performed for
in my life i mean it was like it was
that reminder of the whole point of all
of this of art of music the humanism
inherent in it because
they
cried they cheered they clapped they
were they were the most engaged
um
audience and it was incredible and it
was similar
the um
the street symphony commissioned a piece
of this friend of mine ben who had been
homeless for years and he had stayed he
had intermittently stayed at this
shelter in downtown
um
and so he they street symphony
commissioned him to write a piece and
and they gave the world premiere of it
in the like
commons room like or whatever the like
gymnasium like just the generic big
empty room
um
in this shelter downtown where literally
all the audience
were were people who were like they
probably didn't even know what was going
on that day and i went down there for
that too and and it gives you a real
good sense of that there are some people
who
need
like they need a very intensive
mental health treatment situation but
then there's others
who are they just
they got dealt a succession of really
horrible hands and they don't quite know
life had not equipped them with the
tools to deal with it and they found
themselves in this situation and they're
trying to figure out how to get out of
it and so you get the impression like a
lot of these people
at least the ones that
would find themselves in a place like
this
are they're genuinely looking for how do
i get out of this how do i th this is
not a special once you're there it's so
hard to get out it's the problem it does
seem like america in particular lacks
some safety nets that the rest of the
world kind of has in place to help
people and it's cr i watched this i
watched this youtube video the other day
where this is again where you know my
it's i
like
a lot of supposedly well-meaning
bureaucrats make this much worse because
uh i saw a video of
um
this guy had a homeless
person who was like consistently living
out in front of his house
and he got to know them and was like you
know they have nowhere to go they have
no help so he built like this tiny
little like you know the tiny houses you
know that whole kind of movement of like
these 150 square foot homes that you can
like attach to a trailer hitch and stuff
he built a little thing it was wired for
um
like it had you know it had a um it had
like a little bed and a little sort of
shelf for stuff and some and it locked
crucially um that's always that's a big
problem in in in uh in the homeless um
uh sort of like the the that world is um
people who manage to approve what few
possessions that's stolen all the time
so they can't even like if they they get
a suit to get a job interview if someone
gives them a cell phone or whatever it
could be gone as soon as they fall
asleep so like so he built a thing that
had good lock and it had a little solar
panel on the roof so it could charge a
phone and had a light inside obviously
it didn't go so far as to have like
plumbing or a septic tank or something
but it was basically like here's a place
where you can stay at night
and it's sheltered from the elements and
it locks and it's safe
and they built it for this person and
then he realized you know [ __ ] i i could
do so he he kind of stopped what he was
doing in life and made this kind of like
a little entrepreneurial venture where
he started raising money i think he did
a kickstarter that raised a ton of money
and he started putting these
all over the city and the city uh came
and and destroyed them all confiscated
them all and said
you know you're effectively
incentivizing homelessness by giving
people a home it the the streets are not
zoned for this they came up with a lot
of nimby right very bureaucratically in
my backyard yeah well no it wasn't it
wasn't people it wasn't it wasn't felt
nibby is when like you know the the
classic sort of uh as leonard bernstein
was accused of being the uh the activist
what was the term activist sheikh uh uh
uh that he uh champagne socialist yeah
the limousine liberal is the other term
of like
the that's the ultimate that's the
classic nimby of like oh we have to do
something about this but i don't want
them in my backyard but this was
actually the city of los angeles
uh all right i'm saying this violates
our politics our you know health codes
this week that there are a number of
completely abandoned buildings in
downtown l.a
that the sole purpose that they serve
now is that they are rented out for
productions
so usually completely empty they are
locked um they are left in their
abandoned state you sign a wavy to enter
but productions are allowed to go in so
for a movie or a tv show or whatever
else wants to go in there to use the
space they can and the reason that they
don't just refurbish them to try to make
more money is because the buildings are
already completely owned and some of
them will cost like 25 000 to rent for a
day and that it was like okay
there is obviously a need for that to
exist for people to film in that kind of
building but
in downtown l.a like we really can't
spend the money to convert those like
the housing crisis is not a practical
one in terms of building houses in most
places in the in the western world there
is more than enough housing to go around
it's an economic issue it's ultimately
it's usually the push and pull there are
obviously lots of intersecting factors
i'm i'm oversimplifying but in terms of
are there enough houses or we need to
build more houses for these people
that's not the problem the problem is
we're not letting them into the houses
they exist i know we have most major
cities building as many though
but maybe that only applies to the major
cities because you have to go further
out for the
i think this is very much related to the
thing i was saying my understanding of
it i've never looked super deeply into
this but my understanding of it is
similarly to this guy trying to build
these little uh homes i think in the end
he built something like a thousand
before they were all destroyed wow um
it's a zoning thing like a lot of these
people who want to build low-cost
apartment housing and whatnot the city
council that's where the nimby thing
rears its head is you get these people
that live in these you know suburban
areas and they're like well i don't want
to put some i don't want some 90 unit
apartment put in in my neighborhood so
they go to the city council meetings or
whatever and they they they turn it down
and the the the zoning laws basically
empower that to happen and so it
prevents
the
um
it prevents a market reaction basically
because you know there's there's
you're right
there's an there's a need
and there's a lot of
you know people that would respond to
that need and say oh i can i can offer a
solution here but there's just a there's
the red tape in doing so is the problem
with the market approach is that it
doesn't work at the start of the process
so the problem so what you're describing
is the symptom right it's it's it's
someone is homeless that's that's an
outcome of a series of problems that
happened upriver and that the market's
not so good at solving those kind of
problems because they're more invisible
they're more tricky i don't deny that
where social you know structures this is
where i help you know mental health uh
support and financial support for people
who need it and you know even just
things like unemployment benefits and
stuff the number of people who've become
homeless because
one paycheck didn't come through right
there's so many people in the world who
are living paycheck to paycheck to
paycheck that like one bad month i think
it's majority
of people
it is i i remember looking at the
statistics and it is yeah it's most
american it's definitely me for most of
my life yeah me too i think most
americans only have
enough in their bank account to cover
one month of rent and that's generally
all people can actually afford so you're
right we i lived in my overdraft for
like it's embarrassing to say for about
10 years and yeah if i'd had if i got
laid off i could
you know fortunately i was in a country
had some safety nets if that happened
but like if i didn't then i'd be
that's a serious problem
and i definitely agree i agree we can
definitely help both ends right of that
problem you can you can make it easier
make it less likely that people become
homeless and then help those who have
tried to solve problems preemptively
which i feel like we don't do very often
um
we don't
we don't look at cities
it's true we don't look at cities that
don't have high homelessness rates and
go how do we prevent people from coming
homeless i feel like it's it's always
when it's already happened by
circumstances something else and i'm
sure we could find very great ways to
apply this to game design in some kind
of correlation um but i have to go wait
did troy stop by at some point no he he
uh i think there was a miscommunication
on the start time and then he he he
texted me and was like oh crap i
i i would have to leave in like two
minutes so isn't it always the same
start time am i being it is the same
start time everything's always the same
yeah
he texted and he goes i might be the one
who's wrong here and i said i think you
might be
[Laughter]
and uh
troy will never will never be one to
shirk responsibility uh we didn't talk
about the matrix demo we didn't talk
about that
people annoyed about that i i definitely
want to talk about both of those things
i would love to talk to you about i
watched your video on the matrix demo i
thought my [ __ ] mind man i thought it
was super yeah i could tell you were
excited yeah um i was also gonna say i
it's obviously it's christmas next week
which is what how um but i'm still down
to record we took it off last year but i
can still record on the 21st i don't
know we'll figure it out recording yeah
we won't make everyone else bigger
admin issues
listen everybody i'm a lot of a video
game writer that's also wintery he's a
video game that's michael he's a game
director bye i'm available to record
over christmas good to know me too thank
you